NARRATOR: Finally,
the [inaudible] leader
agrees to talk.
[non-english speech].
He is speaking on
behalf of everyone.
He says, yeah, I'm a pastor.
I'm a leader.
I'm a Christian.
I'm a father.
But this belief is
part of my life.
And I can't just take it out.
It's part of me.
How can I extract it?
[non-english speech].
INTERPRETER: People
admit themselves and say,
we have [non-english].
But it does have to do--
But people confess.
INTERPRETER: Yeah, they
admit to having it.
Huh.
It escapes me why
they would do that.
So people do confess.
And sometimes they'll
say, it wasn't me.
It was the one from over there
or the one from over there.
And they'll tell us, and we have
no idea, so we just believe it.
It's a good [non-english]
and bad [non-english].
[non-english speech].
One is good thinking.
And the other
one is dangerous.
Oh, [non-english].
This is [inaudible],
one of our accused.
Hello.
INTERPRETER: Her
mother was murdered.
She's accused.
Her son is accused.
So they're all within
the same family.
So he believes that she
has this [non-english]
spirit inside her.
[non-english speech].
So he said, how would we
know if she has [non-english]?
It's a spirit.
You can't see a spirit.
We've been told by
people who would
know because they're
also [non-english].
[inaudible] has it.
So we believe it.
[non-english speech].
INTERPRETER: I was
going to kill her,
but then she said
she didn't have it.
It wasn't her.
But then the others
turned around
and said, no, it was her, so.
[non-english speech].
So I asked him,
in your own life,
your wife was accused of being
a [non-english] and murdered.
Now, do you think--
- She was murdered.
His wife was murdered.
INTERPRETER: So do you think
that she was correctly accused?
[non-english speech].
There's is no way that
my wife was [non-english].
I don't accept that.
Her family, my family,
and I myself and I believe
she was not [non-english].
And it was completely
falsified accusation.
[non-english speech].
INTERPRETER: But they
killed her anyway.
But when there's
a bad [non-english],
do people believe it is
OK to then kill them?
You have to kill them?
It's OK to kill them?
Is it the right thing to do?
We must kill them then.
NARRATOR: This man, this
priest, whose own wife
was falsely accused,
still believes
that witches must be punished.
In so many ways
this tells me how
deep and intractable the belief
in [non-english] is here.